if your parented well you can see it
from a mile away
and when you're not you can see it from
a mile away and I think too many parents
view their kids as a product
[Music]
we need to do a much better job zero to
18 to understand somebody's makeup their
emotional makeup their skillset the way
we do school today and the way we
structure our kids for success in the
first 18 years is so broken worldwide
for a lot of parents their kid is a
representation of them and that's where
it breaks it breaks if a parent thinks
that a kid's accomplishment is a
reflection on them because now you have
a disconnect now you're not a parent and
a child
you're a person with a product and I
think that that is scary to me because
going to Harvard or Stanford or Yale is
a badge that people back in Beijing walk
around proudly to their contemporaries
and they're [ __ ] their kids up if you
look at America as a proxy when the
middle class started to emerge it was
also when University in college was
starting to build as a brand and it
worked for a period of time that was
fine but the problem is technology is
too much of a variable if you want your
kids to be successful recognize that the
world you live in today has nothing to
do with the world they're gonna live in
that social I appearance where those
same pressures who came from those same
places who refused to treat me that way
and that's why I'm gonna be special
I want that for the gazillions of kids
around the world because they deserve it
the fact that 99 out of 100 parents back
in Chinese New Year put unneeded
pressure on their kids which ultimately
is going to hurt their children and hurt
their relationship with their children
is needs to start being eradicated
well thieves please in China that is an
optimism it's very optimistic point of
view is the government is now
encouraging graduates taken to preneur
ship is the first job I think it's great
that it's pushing kids to
entrepreneurship my problem is 9 out of
10 of these Chinese kids that are 22
years olds that are jumping into
entrepreneurship have no chance cuz
they're not entrepreneurs yes but good
because it's efficient yes but you have
to be careful because the one thing I
fear is when these kids fail and almost
all of them will it's a very big scarlet
letter
that culture and I think psychologically
you're putting a 23 year old in a very
vulnerable spot where now they have a
loss publicly there's no hiding when you
lose in school like I did you can blame
people when iris loses at vaynermedia
she can blame me when you work at a
company or when the government's
involved or when at school
you can blame somebody else when you
have a business it's your fault so I
would caution one thing for anybody
who's listening who thinks
entrepreneurship is such a freedom when
you lose you have to make sure that
you're mentally stable enough to be able
to take all that cynicism and the
critiques from everybody including your
friends your friends parents your
parents because if you don't you start
going down a very dangerous path that
leads to a very scary place we do not
reconcile why we why we have suicide in
America at the teenage level it's
because modern parenting is over
coddling kids to an extreme level where
kids don't know how to deal with
adversity
I think self-awareness matters much more
than being an entrepreneur for you and I
the learning makes sense it's our DNA I
look at every loss as learning that is
not how people are wired we need to do a
much better job zero to 18 to understand
somebody's makeup so go deeper you know
there are a lot of new family that
they're just newly became the middle
class so yes no claps of booming so
they're afraid that they're gonna lose
because they just got there you know
like the only way that they can think of
to to maintain this status is to invest
in their kids education or push a little
bit harder to make sure their kids can
carry on the status again also so that
that that's what they're wrong yeah I
understand they're gonna lose what they
don't understand is how quickly the
world is evolving and how and how we're
all more connected than ever and we're
all looking at each other's cultures I
think the greatest thing that is ever
gonna happen to America is China's
emergence
so I think kids that are gonna be born
ten years from now are gonna be winners
in America forty years from now because
of the chip on their shoulder of losing
that world stage leadership so what
should parents invest in their kid of
what aspect one thing I would tell
parents is do a lot more listening and
don't listen to your [ __ ] friends you
know listen listen listen to your kids
and when I say listening watch them what
do they gravitate towards nobody thought
playing video games 20 years ago was
gonna lead to a luxurious financial life
it clearly has
[Music]